う”ぅ”前髪ないよぉ
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
というわけで、すいませんちょっとお酒を飲んでおります　ふふふ
あの今、超久しぶりに
トミックさんが上に来ております
［拍手］
いや、マジ久しぶりでね
こう色々会えなかった時のいろんな話をね
こう語り、語りながらお酒を飲んでると
ベロンベロンに酔っぱっらっちまいました
まぁ僕はまぁ見ての通りもうボロボロなんですけど
トミックさんがちょうど今多分ね
ちょうどいいそんな飲み過ぎてもないぐらいの
ちょうどいい感じに酔っ払っていると思うので
なんか動画を撮るのであれば
この酔っているター(イ)ミングがまた一つ
味があっていいのではないかな
一興一興ということで
このタイミングで動画を撮っていこうと思います
よろしくお願いいたします
というわけで昔もやったことあるんですけども
トミックさんにある言葉を言わすまで
終われない動画
パンッ
パ  パンッ
パ パンッ
ハイッ
パンッ
パ パンッ パン パンッ
ハイッ ハイッ
ツイッターでぱらっと募集するよ
ターゲットトミックさんにある言葉を言わせます
その言葉を言わせるまで僕は動画を終わることができません
言わせるべき言葉は今からツイッターで募集しますので
その中から選びます
もっとこうなんか…難しいやつが欲しんよぉ
はっはは…ばかやろう
お前らｗ
わけわかんねぇーよｗ
よしわかりました、今日のテーマは
コンセントでいきます
やばい酔ってて目が赤い
頑張れーこれ終わったら寝る
というわけで
コンセントは終わりません
というわけで、というわけでトミックさんはなんとかして
色々駆使して絶対そのこ、単語は使わないんですけども
なんとかしてコンセントって言わるまで終われない動画
行ってきます
痛い
ウォウウォ　トミックさん
ウォウウォ
トミックさんウォウウォ
はじめ）ウォウウォ
トミック）ウォウウォ
はじめ）トミックさんウォウウォ？
はじめ）ウォウウォ
トミック）ウォウウォ
はじめ）遊ぼうぜ　トミック）何して？
はじめ）早く
トミック）なに？
はじめ）見てて、見てて見てていきます
はじめ）いきます
はじめ）シュッ
はじめ）見てて、リピートアフタミー
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】
逆再生
はじめ）ﾄｩﾙﾙﾄｩﾙﾙﾄｩﾙﾙ
はじめ）間違えちゃったごめんなさい
トミック）はははｗｗ
はじめ）oh ~
はじめ）サーッ！
はじめ）ﾄｩﾄｩﾝﾄｩﾄｩﾝﾄｩﾄｩﾝ
はじめ）ｗｗなんてそれｗｗ
トミック）んん？ｗなに？
はじめ）ドンキーコングこんなことしないっすよｗ
トミック）はははｗｗ
はじめ）あっ　うぉ
はじめ）おい見ろよ
はじめ）わははは
はじめ）おぉい見ろよ
はじめ）おぉう
はじめ）ナイス！